This video doesn't contain an exhaustive list of everything you
might have related to exploratory data analysis. But here are
some of the things that we thought about. If you
have other ideas, please share your thoughts on the forum. The
first thing I notice is that Nathan used histograms to
show the distribution of TV sizes in any given year.
You can also see that for each year, Nathan included
a dark line in the middle. Which represents the median size
television for that year. So in 2005, it looks like
the median TV size was about 40 inches. So half
the TVs were larger and half of them were smaller.
Second, Nathan describes where the data originated. In this case he
got his data from CNET Reviews. Nathan describes a caveat
in the source of his data. He mentioned that the
screen sizes are based on the TVs that were on
the market at the time and not on how many people
actually bought them. The average television size that people
bought could be quite different from the average television size
on the market. I think the second part is key
and is something we should remember when approaching any data
set. We should always be skeptical of what story the
data may tell. We should ask questions about our data,
inspect it and consider its context. Finally, Nathan conducted a
time series analysis. So each year after 2002, Nathan indicates
whether the median size of televisions increased
or whether or not it decreased. In
the case of the circle, we know that the television size remained the same.
This leaves me wondering what television sizes are doing now. Maybe you can find
some data out there and let us know by the end of the course.